spéciale vidéo aujourd'hui
nous allons exposer des gens
Ainsi,
le YouTuber belge Assets a commencé à poster des vidéos.
il a révélé les noms
des membres de l'association belge des étudiants
Les géants
Ils ont été condamnés pour la mort de Sandadia.
le garçon de 20 ans
Il est décédé il y a 5 ans après une seule initiation.
Il devait se tenir dans de l'eau glacée.
1 poisson-globule vivant à manger et de l'huile de poisson salée à boire
Sandra s'est évanouie
Il n'a été conduit à l'hôpital que des heures plus tard.
Les 18 membres de l'association ont été condamnés à une amende pour cela.
en 1 peine d'amende
cela fait 1 espoir pour les gens 1 une peine légère
même le YouTuber Acid pense que la punition n'est pas suffisante
Il veut annuler les garçons.
Les noms qu'il partage dans la vidéo
photos et détails sur 4 garçons
dont 2
n'étaient pas directement impliqués dans l'incident
la vidéo a été supprimée par YouTube
parce que cela constituerait de l'intimidation
Il a déjà été mis en circulation
et d'autres personnes exposent les garçons en ligne
les personnes qui sont impliquées
Merquez que les noms roulent
un restaurant comme celui-ci
des parents de l'un des garçons
dernière des réservations fantômes et de mauvaises critiques
"acid dit lui-même dans sa story Instagram"
encore 6 jours de bannissement sur YouTube
alors nous allons partir